I'm coming man you slow come on Earl get
in the elevator I want to be tow Jim
sometime that's not going to happen yeah
I
know come on
yeah you ready big girl yeah I'm ready
to jam all right let's do this come
on my name is toam and I'm big ear M we
come from out SP
wo oh oh we crashed down on this planet
it was an accident this is a crazy Place
hey hey tell them to
J yeah
yeah FY
down get
funky yeah
yeah monkey down and
fun
these crazy Earths dressing out this
crazy world is upside down you know that
little funy sound is all we need here
give him that give me some BG maybe
that's
all get
that oh yeah it's all they need slap
that
that oh maybe that's all they need got
to give
that all they
need my name is to and I'm big ear mm we
got a message to give to you wow wow we
coming at you from bunker Tron bun Tron
and you you need to chill it out let me
tell talk to him tell them look t o to
the E jamming on the beat and I a big
ear make them stand to feet uh crash
landed on a strange Planet trying to
find a pieces but this place is gigantic
running from the bees and dodging all
the moles somebody tried to run me over
with a lime more maybe all they needs a
little fun maybe that's all they
need these crazy Earth stressing out
this crazy world is upside down you know
that little funky sound is
our uh uh yeah you got to Feel the Funk
from F TR come on shake your thing and
get it on you can't hate when you
feeling the FK yo just let it go in the
funk you flow
yeah give that f hey hey hey hey hey
[Music]
hey thatu well well well well well well
that hey hey hey hey hey come on
[Music]
that here it
is give that
f
[Music]
that Fu feel the phone all right Earl
let's go let's take care of some
business I'm with you Tow Jam I got you
[Music]
back